you guys remember the song by four
non-blondes it goes
i say hey all right
[Music]
yeah finish it up i like it
[Applause]
that's your part
so obviously we do not need to rehearse
that
all right this happened to me when i was
a
kid i woke up one morning when i was a
kid
i wanted to get some
breakfast on home
maybe some eggs and bacon
and then i rubbed my eyes and put my
feet on the floor i looked down the
parent's door and i
saw something
a little peculiar
it was my mom and my dad and they were
wrestling around and my mom she made
some pretty weird sounds and i screamed
at the top of my lungs
[Applause]
you know the words
[Music]
thank you very much